hey what's up everybody welcome to the
are you garbage comedy podcast
yes gang hit that subscribe button to
make sure that you get the episodes as
they come out welcome to another
exciting edition of ru garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley baby hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
are you garbage the show where we sit
down with your favorite comedians and
find out they grew up classy or if
they're complete trash I'm your host H
probably coming at you on yet another
beautiful day here at gas digital
studios in the East Village
or what's left of it did I say I made
Foley already thanks Mike I'm not used
to being her happy boy what I don't know
what's going on my co-host is sitting
right [ __ ] next to me for the first
time in a long time
dang he is the brains behind the
operation he put the whole [ __ ] thing
together he does the books he cooks him
he does it all
we're staying one step ahead of the law
give it up for my good pal mr. Kevin
James Ryan hey gang happy to be here
thanks so much for tuning in if you're
listening if you're new please make sure
you rate review subscribe on iTunes also
the full video is available on YouTube
you can subscribe there as well also if
you're new to gas digital you can sign
up for guest digital use promo code a yg
you will save a dollar 50 a month for as
long as you are signed up plus Wiegand
to wet our beaks a little bit love that
money keep keep the big man flush with a
couple of hollows Lenny and small
smaller shirts
yikes buddy you are falling out of that
thing shout out to the Georges
collection of all Mart save my summer it
was a tarp cover guys thanks so much you
can sign up use promo code a yg and you
can get you know HD live streaming you
get full ax
all the catalog of all the shows on the
network as well the full library's a lot
of cool [ __ ] so check that out yes sir
and we could not be more excited to have
our very special guest in studio with us
today
another one from [ __ ] Jump Street off
the streets of Philadelphia our old pal
you seen him in the movies many love of
Benjamin army wives you seen him on
laugh tracks got them comedy live he has
his own video series look at it this way
and you know from unpopular opinions
ladies and gentlemen he is a strong
proud beautiful black man best [ __ ]
pals and we love them but the big
question anybody's mine today is he
garbage give it up for dayz temple
what's happening man wow what a
beautiful black things gonna take a run
at you later oh my god what do you mean
what's that Dave's gorgeous Ray's a
good-looking guy this guy word on the
street kids got a hug see coming down
the street it's the first one to have
Corona that day I never under you know
it's so funny it's good to be around
that energy with you guys again cuz I've
only been around my black comic friends
and we never referenced each other's
dicks wait wait till we get to the
questions the intro we're already
talking about the Johnson will you show
me your penis just a one track mind with
you guys Jesus black guys don't do the
gay [ __ ] I learned that early on I first
start hanging out with black guys on the
game what's up grab the red whoa oh my
god Dave thank you so much for sitting
with this funny [ __ ] we were chatting
a little bit over the quarantine we kept
tabs on each other it's good to see it
it's [ __ ] it's really nice to be here
in the studio it is man it is especially
I had to get to you guys face to face I
know you guys been [ __ ] big dogging
me a little bit
all right I send you guys text messages
you don't get back to me till the next
[ __ ] day I don't know when that star
I'm not doing a [ __ ] myspace live
show I apologize I have some don't win
the [ __ ] that started happening buddy I
respond to everybody all the time check
pull up the dumpers bill and pull up my
cell phone you know I'm glad you guys I
knew you guys would pull through on the
other side cuz you guys are [ __ ]
Philly trash just like me throwing
through me there's no need to check on
it get off my back
holy [ __ ] Dave temple uh tell us about
where you grew up what the situation was
oh man so I grew up in South West
Philadelphia and I bounced up you said
that like you're on the local news he's
plugging the website after a fire 60p
King says sin and a lot of time back and
forth between there and Delaware County
oh yeah come out there into the Darby's
the Aidan's the Upper Darby
Oh face of urban trash is way worse man
a suburban trash is worse because one
there's like more area for stuff to show
your trash you know there's a couple
more bucks to so like they don't know
how to spend money it's tough and you
don't have to keep it in line out there
you can be the full [ __ ] that you are
in the city you got to be careful you
can't run your math you can't do certain
things you get out there with the
[ __ ] cul-de-sacs live it's [ __ ]
wide open yeah well you know the other
thing about the counties especially when
I was growing up everyone was like first
generation when that new was first
generation in the counties really they
had no idea how to maintain property
they're out there with the weed whacker
trying to do the whole backyard using
the lawnmower on the snow you watch the
neighborhood deteriorate when we got so
what was out there though they laid you
out there everybody like basic your
family went like okay so a little-known
fact I know this is gonna start from
growing up growing up we might be
forward that dicks 18 they can vote oh
come on
where were you but where were you born
you're born in South West Philly yeah
yeah yeah all right and you're in and
you guys live there yes okay who's we me
and my mom so my mom and dad they
weren't together like they were like
dating a little bit or she got pregnant
[Laughter]
my papa's front of richard allen homes
north philly and my mom she from
Southwest cops Creek wait who's Richard
Allen Holmes the Richard
they're the same projects there's an old
movie star
I've never seen any of his films Lucy
pre John Wayne Richard Alan Holmes so
same process as Cosby my pop got good he
he kind of pieced out like around month
- okay and it was basically because
where my mom lived because he wasn't
from the neighborhood that dudes would
kind of give him a lot of [ __ ] coming in
and out dude I would be out yeah like
the kind of like you know who you here
to see like I'm just here to see my son
oh oh oh you got son with Tony like you
know to me so it was like he would come
out to like people sitting on his car a
challenging Eamon [ __ ] like that that's
something you do if you go to a cookout
you get yelled at by kids in the
neighborhood you leaving on coming not
when it's your two month old son you go
I don't know take a little abuse [ __ ]
that part yeah my mom definitely always
looked at him as like he was
[ __ ] for that like oh really you're
gonna let these [ __ ] stop you from
seeing your son it's like yeah I don't
want that kind of energy just leave my
mom's house and who was in Delaware
County that you went back and forth oh
man so we used to use different
addresses to go to school laughter
that's great here we go gang that's
garbage but I've let your [ __ ]
seatbelt we do I gotta say that is trash
I've had friends that do that as
definites like a game of three-card
Monte school I can say this because I've
said it on my special and enough time
has passed everyone used that address
like you use that for car insurance you
you register like it was just every like
every family member that had our last
name was coming out of this one house
and game wasn't even the house is an
empty lot this guy's on a lot of cars
but I respect that because that's like
that's that's trying to better off 100%
that's that's your mom's trying to be
like right I got it I got a pivot and
get out of the garbage level I am to the
next level you know what I mean and
what's up to is they get that [ __ ] so
stupid I mean I understand school
districts and all that kind of stuff but
when you have like one area that gets
like zero funding and you literally live
[ __ ] you know a street away from
going to the good school district or
going to the shitty school district you
got a [ __ ] you got a hustle a little
bit you got to play some [ __ ] game
daddy I'm all about gun corners what
does this look like and who was the
family that lived in Delaware County
whose actual house was it oh I became my
mom yeah my mom oh so they just you
moved up okay all right very nice how
old were you when you got when you guys
moved out there and would your dad go
out there to see here or was he scared
of those kids out there they eat in
street tuff's
now that's a bunch of white kids like
he's a grown man rolling bagels Adam
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
and did you have brothers and sisters
growing up that was an only child until
I was about 15 and then I went back to
the city to live with my aunt and I
became number 13 so I went from Jim by
myself you know was good about a family
coming in and out to boom now I'm child
number 13 so I got it was 13 kids
involve already there what yeah yeah
holy [ __ ] all your aunt had 12 kids
eight and then like his dad was supposed
to gate that was her husband he came he
came grievously and then he died while
she was pregnant with the youngest
hambo and that was in South West Village
yeah she was doing 12 on our on her own
and now it's a romantic way to look at
it so you know I've made like I am a
typical I'm a typical case of like my
mom worked her ass off she did good I
was an idiot I was an idiot like I
wonder you though you're not an idiot I
wanted more than she could afford and
when my mom put it on me to go get it
myself
I used bad judgment so that's when I got
involved with the streets and the scam
in and the stealing and drug dealing and
[ __ ] like that
Oh for me mom found me with basically
valves of DRO or my nightstand like I
own this place and a gun under my
mattress and she was like you gotta go
you know I never thought about cutting
lawns or paper route and saying I was a
total [ __ ] I had a job I had my first
job at 14 - [ __ ] yeah I had my first
well my first job was a [ __ ] drug it
was a that's not a job no no no no my
first job I worked a Dunkin Donuts at 14
mopping floors all right there you go
everybody I worked with was a drug
dealer okay and I learned about working
a job to cover up the fact that you deal
drugs
yeah and that this was the the Duncan so
I used to work at the Dunkin Donuts real
rattlin and 70th an island and it was a
it was a drug school it was where I
learned everything about usually in that
situation it doesn't make for great
customer service I'm just gonna have
[Laughter]
worked with a Jamaican guy who used to
drive a Jeep like one of those jeeps
with the lights and their mission ragtop
roof and he would come back down take
all of his gold rings off to make donuts
that's awesome like this guy he but he
was Jamaican he had that work ethic and
he goes no you always keep a paycheck
and that way you can at least explain
maybe you wanted in a dice game
you're good at investing but why you
have a rhinoceros riding backyard so
where does Cougar come from let's go
but I'm 14 years old and I'm mopping
floors for 515 an hour bucket and I got
you know dope boys that are showing me
knives and cans why they're making
donuts and teaching me like this is real
money this is how you take care of your
family you're good you got work ethic
you get up and you come here and you do
this but this ain't how you get ahead
you know I mean and I listen to that
dumb [ __ ] when we were fine that I I got
into the whole concept oh I need sell
drugs take care of my mom my mom was a
computer programmer for belapur she
didn't need you selling dime bags
I Pearl's got a 401k dad still paying
this is all for her you get her nothing
for Christmas
he's got the four finger ring and the
triple fat goose aw so I went and I saw
it but when my mom realized what I was
doing she now as an adult I totally
understand it
oh you totally jeopardize her livelihood
like as I watched the guys when I'm with
the college because I was a smart kid
you know to me when I went to college
and I saw the guys that were stuck
around and started continuing to deal
drugs like post high school yeah yeah
and like we're getting their mother's
doors Wow rein it in and it's like you
know I watched my friends get raided
December 21st they [ __ ] the cops
knocked the mothers doors off the hinges
and left them like that for Christmas
and these kids couldn't afford to pay
for [ __ ] they couldn't even hire a
contractor that's when I was like oh
[ __ ] this was the wrong path you know
and I mean thank God and my mom was
totally right to get me the [ __ ] away
from her you know enemy because I had no
idea that that was the reality that that
was the result of Chiron the lifestyle
you know I mean that could happen now
you see obviously you went to Pitt daddy
mercy and he went through which is a
[ __ ] great square MA okay so I should
be I should be like a scientist dude I
should be where you started coming yeah
I got I got two degrees one in
mathematics and one in economics all
right so but I don't know I just like
[Laughter]
when I was in college and all of my
professors I looked at the guy like I no
one wants to [ __ ] that guy I don't want
to be that guy no one wants to [ __ ] the
math professor that's covered in [ __ ]
chalk and Lawson foundation with the
Jamaican guy with the [ __ ] rings on
and maybe a little bit of powdered sugar
on his shoulder he was getting late yeah
and I mean it's sex was a big [ __ ]
thing for me sex was a big motivator you
know what I mean that was my motivation
to take a shower get a haircut you know
to me and like anything so holy
mine was Elios pizza and the a-team and
what new GI Joe was hittin the market so
I was doing I was doing like I would do
basically college
get money to have access to women but it
was like a this was I was someone sigh
guys started getting around women keep
in mind I became a dad at like 1920 you
know what I mean oh yeah so like I was
in college right so the whole concept
now became my main priority in college
was dollar beer night that's crazy yeah
okay so Eve had you work that out in the
dorms where was the kid on I think in
the apartment off-campus yeah so like so
like all right you got a like for me
once the streets got a hold of me and
I'm at my aunt's house right I'm Juliana
holder nice [ __ ] cuz this is what I'm
doing you and remember all you have you
had social promotion in in middle school
or in high school back in Philly right
social promote as long as you pass
English and gym you can move on to the
next grade I didn't know that that's
really [ __ ] up man
I had been an academically talented
classes since I was like in fourth grade
right it's not years old so after my
freshman year of high school I'm pretty
much guaranteed a diploma I've already
outperformed everyone here okay so now
I'm coming to school like my senior year
I'm coming to school for periods I'm
coming for the free breakfast homeroom
you know what I mean I might do I had
gym in English there's a track on a high
school for the continental lunch and I'm
out I'm out of school every day by 12:40
I would just blow off the whole second
half of the day and that would leave me
time to now go back home and hit the
block with some other knuckle here
tonight you know but I felt like I could
take care of myself because my I put me
on a very very long leash my aunt she
really didn't my aunt had 12 other kids
to worry about her thing was look you're
at the bottom of that priority exactly
and you just got here alright so started
getting the toothbrush so at the time I
had a pager my ID still was look at 10
o'clock the heavy gate gets locked
we got keys to the door but not the
heavy gate so at 10 o'clock it's locked
I don't open it for anybody else if
you're not in by 10:00 you're out it's a
solid rule though I got to give her that
it's right
rule do me a favor define the heavy gate
is that like a screen door I guess it's
a screen door and the suburbs but like
in the hood it's a heavy steel metal
ball I know exactly what you're talking
I've got a whole deadbolt to it you know
to keep people from kicking the door in
a break yeah you could lose a finger in
those things if it's slam hood rat just
write a very heavy screen door yeah yeah
well we call it the heavy gate you know
I mean you know when you go through the
hood you see the houses with the bars
and the windows and the doors yeah I
lived in one of those okay so I would
basically at 16 I'm on his long leash
where I can make my own decision at 10
o'clock where I'm going home enough yeah
you know what I mean and my aunt would
just kind of page me in the morning and
be like are you alive
are you eating are you going to school
as long as I answered yes to those three
questions
mine didn't give a [ __ ] you're not a
mention guy she's just too preoccupied
insuring so that's where that other [ __ ]
now it was like okay I need to make
money blog I put myself in that position
where now I do have to show up to places
like olden Street and you know stands on
the corner but I wasn't one of those
kids but I try my best to be it it was
it was a stupid stupid period my
guidance counselor recognized I was
[ __ ] [ __ ] up
shout out the doctor on a cone saved my
[ __ ] life man this guy pulled me saw
me skipping class saw me wandering the
[ __ ] halls it was like what are you
doing come in my office he goes you're
you're wouldn't you you're wasting
everything sure and he's basically he
already knew I was a poor kid so he's
like you are you're financially eligible
for five waivers go pick five
applications off the wall fill them out
and bring them in and we'll pay for pay
two application psychologists yeah I
just randomly grabbed Westchester
Cabrini Pitt Xavier in Louisiana and
Temple University you yeah oh wow who
dodged a bullet there literally yeah so
I got accepted the terrible morning
radio literally it's got a time and
temperature right now yeah it's 504 in
your cold
this kid's got [ __ ] ice in his veins
not in a good way
always [ __ ] when I was in high school in
front of McDonald's it was you know what
I'm talking about man he was arrested in
the parking lot of this thing this is
how was to wait save this story again
who got shot like he was just a kid but
he was from the same zip code as me and
I think that's why I didn't get in
um I think it's why I did get into to
you because I don't think they were
accepting kids from our area that
following year really yeah yeah yeah man
that's [ __ ] up what you get in your
SATs train leaves now what do we get
when we get in a McDonald would you get
your SATs 1100 without a big dude and I
only took the SAT because my girlfriend
in high school promised to have sex with
me afterwards pick her up dry I didn't
even want a good she was that
pro-education she she she she child 9 if
you know what I mean yeah she was
another one it's just like what are you
doing you're just being a [ __ ] like
wire like you don't want to go to
college and I was just in this really
self-destructive mode and she was just
like dude you gotta take care of cities
you gotta just see what you get so like
all right you know and I had a car so
that was the deal like I picked her up
we went took the SATs together I forgot
a [ __ ] calculus
that's how much I cared about this [ __ ]
you know what I mean and doctor leader
for your SATs for the math I didn't
really need it for the math portion
makes a lot of sense to me
I got 870 both what'd you get
1111 II took them once mm-hmm they're
like as long as you get above 1100 and
get to whatever you know the schools
that I wanted to go to exactly good
night don't yeah you increase it if you
increase you know y'all clear by 40
points if you think it again I'm like yo
buddy yeah the first time I've been up
before 7:00 again like you missed a big
kegger in there my Gaddis counselor
tried to get me to take it again and get
a higher score I'm like [ __ ] that like
just send it in like cuz I didn't even
really want to go to college I've been
thinking about it I went because then
that summer I got into theft and fraud
[Laughter]
Thank You University of Pittsburgh you
used to do this [ __ ] we've talked about
it before you gotta get into some
questions here at some point yeah
problem we have close friends I'm
especially now that we're in persons
like we forget about the game and we
just start [ __ ] I think we're
learning a lot I only got an 1100 what
do you want um [ __ ] what we gonna say
[ __ ] I just lost my train of thought
sorry
we gotta get to some questions I know I
know but there was something else I
apologize something about the SATs all
right you told me your story - on the
way to New York there's a lot of like
bags lined with tin foil and stuff
that'd be walking out of Bloomingdale's
that's how I met baby mama number one
baby mama no more like baby blue [ __ ]
belly belly
please nothin when I met my first baby
mom she was boosting out of Burlington
Coat Factory in downtown Pittsburgh and
I was lunch thing you might steal it you
act like you've never pinned a [ __ ]
called McDonald's but yeah we got into
that's how I met her I thought I saw her
and
the girl from school running out of a
burlington and the sensors going off and
i recognized him from school and that's
s correct
at that age yeah I'm like okay okay and
we started we started stealing like
velour sweat suits like the Sean John
and Rocawear that was hot blue so we
would get that [ __ ] and get the soft tag
sensors off and sell them on campus that
sex has got to be great man after after
all that excitement really sad Bonnie
and Clyde's I got I got the pants and a
medium anybody got it anybody got a
medium top I got the box VIN let's go
we're going home to [ __ ] yeah so dad
that was it you know but I got into that
in Philly and it got a little bit out of
control at a a job that I was working
and the only thing that saved me from
catching a major case because it caught
up with me it took a while to catch up
with me but based on the fact that
legally I was still a resident of my
mother's house but I hadn't been in my
mother's house in like three years
so when warrants were posted for me
they're going to my mother's house
looking for me and my mom never gave it
up my mom never like told him where to
find me she just he's not here right so
even though they're they're constantly
coming and Sheriff's Office is posting
warrants they were looking for me you
know she would let me know and let me
know to steer clear of it I got accepted
to Pitt I went because of my finger in
the world Pittsburgh is different George
you know that still caught up with me in
Pittsburgh but by that time when I go
before a judge it's like well he's
enrolled in a program here he's never
had any priors and my father was in the
Union shout out the local 98 you know to
me and they pulled a few strings down
there those unions man they pull some
strings yeah man jeez that's pretty good
man
that's a pretty hot day all right I
think it's time to get a little game
grocery-store Sydney do you prefer Rohit
to throw it to commercial we got gonna
hit his smoke a cig and regroup take the
edge off
look over my face is gonna be like a
mine oh my god so not a big Lunchables
family it wasn't big on the ecto cooler
oh yeah no do we like growing up mm-hmm
growing up my mom never bought any of
that [ __ ] and like I my aunts house
there were no snacks around at all like
you we were at my aunts it was a fine
quarters or still laundry money to go to
the local corner store you know I mean
you're getting like Dipsy doodles and
[ __ ] like that but never see doodles are
really really tricky yeah it's it's a to
thick corn chip it's a corn chip that
looks like a Sun chip that wants to be a
Dorito it's all [ __ ] crack a tooth on it
they're they're too thick
sounds like a tow no they were in a
bright yellow bag and it's funny because
you outgrow them because they're only
put on low she'll [ __ ] later any time
I'm in the hood and I look around for
now like I literally have to bend all
the way down to find them I feel like
such a fat ass when I'm in the grocery
store cause they do that with the sugar
cereal you know because they wanted a
kid level so the kids we got a spill oh
my god all right let's give me some
[ __ ] are you garbage questions here
kipper you want to start this well let's
not debate I was joking but that's
serious I want to know when you were in
South West Philly what was the
supermarket and also when you went to
the bar there was none weren't you
listening what are you talking about
supermarket no IgA when I was a kid IgA
international grocers are certain
remember where they were it sounds for
something grocer station but they were
always these awful little stores with
the the poles so that you couldn't get
the shopping cart
stealing stealing a [ __ ] grocery cart
you see someone walking down a street
push one of those you were like that guy
it's always walking on the street thank
you you're not allowed to be walking
down - there's no [ __ ] sidewalk
there's just like a hubcap some pebbles
that's what it was in the city when we
got out to the county it was like
Pathmark
Acme Acme's all right Acme's clean yeah
cuz Pathmark member used to have to put
a quarter in the cart I must only be
serious you guys never had to put the
quarter in to unlock it
what am I gonna ride them home if we
wanted to what are you talking about
stop the burbs buddy do you mean we all
had our own shopping carts rims on leave
it in the street I'm gone you get the
quarterback when you return there's a
lock on the thing and when you push the
thing in it looks like a seatbelt so
once the thing goes in then the quarter
pops back out hold on I look at that see
you know why that would have never
worked with me I look at that and I'm so
garbage I think hey getting a shopping
cart for a quarter shopping cart for a
quarter keep the [ __ ] quarter I'm
putting some [ __ ] 20 [ __ ] weed
whacker agent on that thing
come on bowler in the bottom charge in
the quarter what you make it for that's
true see over that's a pet deposit oh
man you're talking about [ __ ]
stealing a shopping cart because it's
only
[Laughter]
losing money walking around without a
golf go without go back and sell it back
to them for 50 say oh my god
that's [ __ ] holy [ __ ] Oh
oh man Dave have you ever been a part of
a focus group like to get to get money
answer within the calendar year bleak
okay would you pay 25 cents
even worse ones I did these novum
studies where like what you would
Manchurian Candidate yeah like you would
take pills or let them inject you with
stuff and just hope you got the placebo
you know at me they had a facility that
you could come at you check in on Friday
and you're there until Sunday and they
just keep administering [ __ ] to you a
lot of money it would be for like $400
you know I was doing this in college too
if there's anybody from Pittsburgh you
know about those novum studies because
that was the best place to give money
know them that just sounds like an evil
doesn't it dump you in the river one
before the test oh dude I did one for
like streaming services a couple not
honestly not maybe a year and a half ago
not I remember probably here like a
hundred and fifty bucks doing a bottom.i
alright let's go in I get there it's in
a [ __ ] Visa gift card I'm gonna go
small non-sequential bills let's [ __ ]
walking around leaving a [ __ ]
transaction history with this thing get
the [ __ ] out it although you can use
those debit cards to knock off a few
utility bills here and he used to get
him as a Christmas bonus you get a law
firm they say [ __ ] whacking off
like 600 bucks real dress yeah they were
all they were all 25 bucks each and I
own different envelope simply [ __ ]
like I worked for the [ __ ] letter
company company the only focus group I
ever did is one time I was walking
through the mall and this lady walked up
to me I was probably 12 she's like do
you like chocolate pudding oh my god
what about a studio audience ever been a
part of a studio
[ __ ] yeah my first three years in New
York I did so much Judge Judy and up in
that you would just you get on the bus
in like one hundred and tenth Street
mm-hmm and it just takes you out there
you get pizza and you get 75 bucks then
drop you back off in Harlem at like
midnight Jesus do the medical test take
the lac over I get on a Greyhound bus
with a bunch of people used to get like
bedbugs and Jerry Springer yeah wilcos a
real trashy name by the way if you're
not a bald-headed guy that wears golf
shirts all the time like a family
company exclusively works on water he
and I do a medical testing on the dry
cleans his jeans jeans does he put a
crease in them oh yeah Levi's 501 I can
see if you had a pair of Lucky's or
something this dude just doing $29.99
their genes keeping the Wranglers I got
a come on Dave have you or anybody in
your family ever been in the contraption
known as a money booth
that's a telephone booth where you grab
at the dollar family ever stolen was
trying to get the ATM machine on the bus
videos in the city when the guys do the
when they try to get an ATM machine and
they use a car to smash in yeah I always
wanted to do that did you see the one
way to guy he like ties it to the truck
and then Yanks it out but he's standing
there holding the door open and then the
ATM just [ __ ] takes us like you could
tell it like this locates his hip you
know what I mean and it's like [ __ ] the
plan went perfect but now my hip is
dislocated first one in Jersey City
Oregon a city bus other than 80 yes yeah
it might be a prank I don't know filing
cabinet you know search search through
for the listeners search through my
videos look at it this way you could
just type in the hashtag but I
definitely did a video of one of my
videos on that video all right let's get
back on track yeah let's go ahead oh
[ __ ]
oh my god what was the what was it oh to
answer your question I have never been
in it but my kids have done it for their
birthday they have them yeah they're
like everywhere yeah do you put real
money in it or no it's like two ones you
put a lot of money in there but you do
cuz I remember we did it for my youngest
daughter she was like - you know what I
mean so of course she wasn't able to
grab anything and like we suck her we
put her sister in there with her and I
think she was like eight
the time you got I mean so she helped
out a little bit but they got a little
too good at I had a juicer yeah yeah man
I remember the one time they took our
dealership try to make my mom do it was
like crazy Eddie's Auto Sales like
everything family in the Gaza guys
telling his wife to go it you gotta look
ya'll yeah I'm like mom you lick your
[ __ ] arms I'm like we are never
talking again I missed those [ __ ] we're
like your Saturday would end up at a
dealership because they were giving out
hotdogs and pretzels no need to pick up
a new car ya know without the thing it
was weird because it would attract weird
energy to the light so you have a
crowded lot on a Saturday but no one has
any money here to take a test drive just
to kill time and soak up
air-conditioning I like a blow and help
me with that French's mustard have you
ever been on the amusement ride known as
the Gravitron oh yeah oh yeah have you
ever worked through every been to a Long
John Silver like like God exactly [ __ ]
ass yeah that was a huge deal at the
folio oh my god hush puppies all day go
out to Lancaster to do two outlets and
family get it hi
this is trash it's great [ __ ] trash
driving 30 miles 8 9 bucks on a bolo to
get an irregular [ __ ] Tommy Hilfiger
get a pair of Mike's [ __ ] check
I remember being a kid my mom like we're
going to the outlets like up outside
Trenton where have we driving but seems
like I'll give you the [ __ ] money
let's go to Spencer's what are we doing
we used to go to reading outlets and the
outlets and reading we're like in these
mills where you would have to walk up
and down these staircases and basically
these are the girls that was just a mill
I remember there's some old clothes
everybody's wearing coveralls oh I said
it before I think maybe on the Carly
episode my mom used to take me to a sock
factory to get socks or like get like a
gross of them for a nickel why'd you
have to go to like 12 stores to get that
[ __ ] for [ __ ] back to school it was
[ __ ] insane old Navy and out as a kid
hey everything you need an old Navy and
get the [ __ ] out of there all right god
[ __ ] Kennedy over yeah yeah
that's all Jesus Christ all right um
have you ever had a situation in your
car where you needed an oil change okay
or you had a leak an oil leak but
instead of going at it fixed every time
you put gas in your car you just put a
little oil in it oh yeah yeah I work on
cars myself yeah [ __ ] Marco Andretti
here well I refuse to take my car to a
mechanic that'sthat's how much of an
[ __ ] I am like only way I'm taking a
car to a mechanic is if I don't have the
tools to do it myself and I am going to
argue that guy down on how easy this job
[ __ ] about putting on the lift you
could do it right here
but any time I'm getting gas and I see
somebody walking out with just like one
thing oil man yeah that guy's a piece of
[ __ ] I did it a couple of weeks ago on
the way home on the shore back to New
York top it off a little bit well I
checked it because I thought it cuz I
was really pushing the [ __ ] I was a
really pushing the 3000-mile I was up I
like [ __ ] and you know 12 12 K on
that thing so I stopped on that goes
like a three hour ride so I stopped at
the first rest stop to make sure I was
good I was still within the law within
the guidelines kit and Kip that's all he
needs is a little recommendation to
ignore major problems in a car the check
engine light was on in my car I swear to
God for [ __ ] two months and now it's
off and I feel so I feel [ __ ] mark
that off the checklist save two grand
there January last January we're in
Philly we do a memorial show for a good
buddy Chris cotton down in Philly I
catch a ride back to Philly back to New
York we can't be there he wasn't in a
car with his thumb oh oh yeah but the
[ __ ] brakes yeah it's just from the
snow rush that's what he told me into
Russ two weeks later the brakes go
completely I'm going down a hill I gotta
hit the e brake it was a [ __ ] scene
daddy-o til we going through the
turnstile and he's paying the toll he's
like Jesus Christ like yeah that sounds
bad but I was like trying to talk to the
coal guy be like that's just some rust
on the girders you know what I mean you
get embarrassed my wife's car doesn't
even use wd-40 oh god that was real if
you're making a sandwich at home do you
put chips on the sandwich I don't look
down on it but I understand okay but
there's other people who make them a
habit I get Primanti Brothers out in
Pittsburgh like that's their claim to
fame is Jonas fries in the sandwich the
fries is a lot fries is overkill but a
couple of [ __ ] ruffles on there I
reckon I like to disagree with Kevin's
last statement I do not think puttin
fries
I think it's just right okay
just for the record want everybody to
know get well just can I ask you guys a
garbage question please going ahead is
brought up to chips
you guys are from the Philly area has
have either of you gone to the Herr's
potato chip factory not as a field trip
no I didn't even know you could watch
the fresh tips be born because yours you
know what I mean
where's the nursery in here there's
really a cover to get in what's the
cover in this joint no Uggs what the
[ __ ] holy [ __ ]
Dave have you ever sold a timeshare no
have you ever owned a timeshare no have
you ever heard the pitch of a time oh
yeah the pitch to get into this dude I
answered one of those remember them fax
machines were thing and random faxes
would just come in okay yeah they were
just they would randomly send like hey
crews for two people for this price or
for free seems legitimate and if you're
at work doing nothing I [ __ ] called
and investigated and we [ __ ] took it
we flew down to Disney everything was
taken care of like I think we just had
to take care of airfare but an hotel and
to get into the park know the park
tickets for free sit through the
timeshare to get the park tickets which
sort of sit to a seminar right and the
prices are like try 124 dollars a piece
so you know it was just a matter of just
sit and I think it was funny because
they got mad at us once they kind of
double screen doesn't realize we were
too young and didn't make enough money
cuz I was like in my 20s it was just
like me and my girls yeah make four
million dollars a year you may know me
from boosting at formals
try to trade in some FUBU together give
me a weekend give me a weekend and I
remember like high-fiving my girl and
celebrating as we're walking out there
like you did good not saying anything
like
but definitely keep up on the scale no
intentions on buying this shitty
Timeship
I've always wanted to do this with my
with my girl I don't if you guys ever
done it you guys are gonna look - look
go to an open house where you have no
intention of buying the house that's how
I know gladwyn no [ __ ] that's how I
know Bala Cynwyd Lower Merion I know
every house every mansion along
Conshohocken State Road I toured an open
house from 2005 to 2007 so basically
what like the hors d'oeuvres and stuff
dude
all right I'm sick as they go um nice
chocolate chip cookies I'm six-two at
the time I'm heavier so I'm like 255
ballplayers they assume I just signed a
contract and this is like free everyone
having a cell phone like you know the
internet on the phone right I like to
keep a low profile they assumed that was
someone and they showed me everything
I'm very well-versed in wine cellars I'm
very well-versed in the property taxes
throughout gladwyn and everything I
would never want an own a mansion for
the simple fact that I know 40,000 a
year in property taxes 13,000 and
landscaping I'm good buddy
yeah 2,000 a month and utilities [ __ ]
out of here I'm leaving take all the
cookies anybody could someone direct me
to the nearest bus stop great this is
[ __ ] funny thank you so it is six
temple buddy I love you um Kevin garbage
I mean through and through God Jesus
Christ for sure for sure garbage but I
kind of garbage baby yeah anything you
want the gang out there - no Dave temple
comedy calm is the website go there to
check out all my premium content look at
it this way
six foot nothing podcast I'm popular
opinions Temple University I've even got
classic episodes a first world problem
which was a podcast of myself and Chris
cotton all of this stuff is available
with small membership on my website so
go to Dave temple comedy comm check it
out though guys check it out Davis
[ __ ] awesome an old friend of our
you're gonna love everything he does so
check them out for sure absolutely kid
be what he got just make sure you rate
review subscribe on iTunes I think we're
still in the in the charts which is cool
and at Kemah rank comedy on all social
media yes our gang we could not be happy
to be here with the gas digital family
shout out to our producer Dylan Dylan
thank you so much you're the absolute
best we are so excited you guys are all
taking this journey with this stay with
this like Kevin said sign up cast
digital network comp promo code a yg at
age folio nice on Twitter and Foley
grams on Instagram and we will [ __ ]
see you next week say goodbye